here's jen stoltenberg ship and courage
are an inspiration to all of us
i'm pleased that he could join our
meeting today
president zelanski made clear that
ukraine relies on our continued support
and our message to him was equally clear
ukraine can count on us
for as long as it takes
continue to provide
major military and financial help
and today leaders agreed
to strengthen
our support
by agreeing comprehensive assistant
package for ukraine
this includes
secure communications
fuel medical supplies and body armor
equipment to counter mines and chemical
and biological threats and hundreds of
portable anti-drone systems
over the longer term
we will help ukraine transition from
soviet-era equipment
to modern nato equipment boost
interoperability
and further strengthen its defence and
security institutions
all of this shows our commitment to
ukraine's future
and that our commitment is unshakable
a strong independent ukraine
is vital for the stability of the
euro-atlantic area
today at the summit
nato leaders decided
a fundamental shift
in our defense and deterrence to respond
to a new security reality
we will strengthen our forward defenses
we will enhance our bat groups in the
eastern part of the alliance
up to degrade levels
we will transform the nato response
force
and increase the number of high
readiness forces to well over three
hundred thousand
we will also boost our ability
to reinforce
including with more pre-positioned
equipment
and stockpiles of military supplies
more forward deployed capabilities like
air defense
strengthen command and control
and upgraded defense plans with forces
pre-assigned
to defend specific allies
this is the first time since the cold
war that we have these kind of
plans with the pre-assigned forces
they will work
with home defense forces
and
become familiar with local terrain
facilities
and pre-positioned stocks
so that we can reinforce even faster
doing more will cost more
today allies
recommitted to the pledge we made in
2014. to spend at least two percent of
gdp
on defense
since 2014
european allies and canada have spent an
extra 350
billion us dollars
nine allies
now reach or exceed the two percent
targets
19 allies have cleared plans to reach it
by 2024
an additional five have concrete
commitments
to meet it thereafter
two percent is increasingly
seen as a floor
not as the ceiling
allies are also investing more in modern
capabilities
contributing more to nato deployments
and exercises
and we have agreed to increase nato's
common funding
to finance to finance the facilities we
need for reinforcement
as well as more training and more
exercises
command and control
and engagement with partners
we face a radical change
to our security environment
and strategic competition is rising
around the world
so today leaders have endorsed nato's
new strategic concept
and
it is uh published as we speak
and this is the new strategic concept
the current one was agreed in 2010 and
this is very different compared to what
we agreed back then
it makes clear that russia's russia
poses the most significant and direct
threat to our security
in the current concert we state that
russia is a strategic partner
in the current concept we do not mention
china with a single word
in this
allies states that
china's coercive policies
challenge our interests
security and values
the concept
also sets out our joint position
on countering terrorism
as well as cyber and hybrid threats
today we took
other important steps to continue our
adaptation
we are launching the nato innovation
fund
backed by allies it will invest 1
billion euros
in startups and funds developing dual
use emerging technologies
such as artificial intelligence
together with nato's defense innovation
accelerator
for the north atlantic or diana
the new fund will harness the best new
technology for transatlantic security
climate change is a defining challenge
of our time and nato is committed to
playing our part in mitigating the
impact on our security
sorry today
we agreed a new methodology
to map military
greenhouse gas emissions
and we agreed concrete targets to cut
nato emissions
our aim is to cut emissions by nato
bodies and commands
by at least 45 percent by 2030
and move towards
net zero by 2050.
this is an important step for our
alliance
we cannot choose
between having green militaries or
strong militaries
they must be both
so we must maintain our operational
effectiveness
and readiness as we continue to adapt
in a more dangerous and competitive
world
we must work even more closely with
like-minded nations and organizations
this afternoon
our indo-pacific partners australia
japan new zealand and the republic of
korea
will take part in a nato summit for the
first time we will also be joined by the
european union finland georgia and
sweden
today
nato leaders
took the historic decision to invite
finland and sweden to become members of
nato
the agreement concluded last night by
turkey
finland and sweden
paved the way for this decision
i would like to thank
turkey finland and sweden
for accepting my invitation
to engage in negotiations
to find a united way forward
this has been hard work over many weeks
with multiple contacts at many different
levels
senior officials
have had two rounds of talks in brussels
under my auspices
and last night we met
president erdogan president nina storm
and prime minister anderson
and we were able to reach the final
agreement
this is a good agreement for turkey
it is a good agreement for finland and
sweden
and it is a good agreement for nato
and with that i'm ready to take your
questions okay we'll start with cnn
thank you so much um so i have two
questions the first is i'm wondering if
you could talk a bit more about
the meetings you've had over the day
about ironing out the details of the new
horse model and that includes the
question of um permanent basing
and i'm wondering you know
putin has said that finland and sweden's
membership bids don't pose a direct
threat to russia but he has also warned
them about becoming bases for nato
forces or equipment so i'm wondering
whether
nato has any plans to put permanent
bases in those countries now that
they've been formally invited into the
alliance
first of all
the decision to invite finland and
sweden to become members demonstrate
that nato's door is open
it demonstrates that president putin
putin did not succeed in closing nato's
door
nato's door remains open
and it also demonstrates that we respect
the sovereign right of every nation to
choose some path
so we of course respected finland and
sweden when they decided to
stay out of nato for many many years but
then we also welcome them and respect
their decision to join nato
nato allies have already stepped up and
nato has increased its presence
uh in the baltic nordic region
and of course us when they become
members we can do even more together
what we will make sure uh with uh
our presence
is that we are able to defend all allies
uh including of course finland and
sweden
and this links to the first part of the
question
when it comes to this fundamental
shifting of deterrence on defense
this is about air sea land cyber but
when we speak about lan
uh
that entails or is composed of three
main elements
partly more forward presence
we will um
um
enhance reinforce the battlegroups to
have already deployed up to brigade
levels so that's more presence
especially in the eastern part of the
alliance
the second element is more
pre-positioned equipment
we know that actually the more people
can go quite fast
but to move heavy equipment
um battle tanks
ammunition
fuel
all kinds of supplies that take time
so if you have that pre-positioned in
place
then you can move in very quickly with
the personnel
so the second element on top of the
increased presence
will be more pre-positioned equipment
and then on top of that we will have for
the first time since the cold war
pre-assigned
forces
in of course their home countries but
these forces will then rotate in and out
they will train they will learn how to
operate together with a
home forces for instance in the baltic
countries or in poland
or
other places in the alliance
they will
be familiar with the train with the
pre-positioned equipment
and for instance one example of this is
what germany just has announced that
they are now pre-assigning designating a
specific brigade in germany that will
train
and of course work together with the
older the german battle group in
lithuania
and with more pre-positioned equipment
then this
german brigade has a specific
responsibility and uh and another
advantages because they have trained
there and i know the
the the the country to reinforce and
support lithuania if needed so these are
the three elements uh you can also look
at the nato home page you can see more
details are there in the fact sheet
and then of course the announcement by
different allies today
uh makes it um is actually giving a
substance to the decisions that allies
made today
interface ukraine
thank you anna yeah interface ukraine
happy birthday
wanna
and thank you from all of my colleagues
for everything you are doing for us
sorry secretary general question for you
coming back to president zelinski
address what kind of reaction was from
leaders in the room can you give a
little bit more on this what will be the
main message to ukrainian people
do you think it will be possible for
ukraine then when this war will be over
to join nato like sweden and finland
without membership action plan thank you
as the message from the leaders in the
meeting and in the room was a very
strong expression of support
and not only expression of support but
actually they announced additional
systems weapons equipment that allies
nato allies are now delivering to
ukraine
germany made announcements um
um norway made announcements and other
countries made announcements for
additional um
support military support to ukraine the
netherlands also
made announcements on
more heavy weapons
to to ukraine
um so uh
partly this is something we do
it's also as a message indeed but also
in words but also indeeds
but i think also it's very clear that
allies are prepared for long haul
wars are unpredictable
uh but we have to be prepared
for the long haul and that resource that
was also the clear message to
all of us in the room from president
zelinski and our answer was yes we are
prepared
uh because um
they are fighting for their independence
but they're also fighting for values
which are important for nato fundamental
for nato
the sovereignty
the territorial integrity of every
nation
and and therefore this matters for our
security
our focus now is to support ukraine
this war will as most other wars at
storm some stage end at the negotiating
table
but it is important that uh ukraine is
able to get an agreement on their terms
which is acceptable for ukraine and
therefore we know that there is a very
close link between what they can achieve
around the negotiating table and their
strength on the battlefield and
therefore our focus now is to support
them on the battlefield with many
different types of legal and non-lethal
support that is the focus
and then of course we have demonstrated
today that nato's door remains open
and and we also reiterate the decision
we made in bucharest
on membership for ukraine
spanish television
welcome to madrid
you don't have a crystal ball but i was
wondering how much longer do you think
it's going to take for finland
and sweden to join the nato since it's a
pretty urgent situation
thank you very much well so far this is
the fastest
accession protocol ever accession
process ever
because
finland sweden applied for membership in
may and now
at the end of the june
leaders invite them to become members
and we will assign
the accession protocol and
and and and then what remains of course
is uh
uh is the ratification in 30 parliaments
uh i cannot speak on behalf or promise
anything on behalf of 30 different
parliaments but the message in the room
uh is that throughout the alliance there
is a strong will to
work with parliament so they can do the
ratification as soon as possible so
this
this has moved fast so far and of course
i expect that the allies are ready to
also ratify as soon as possible but at
different procedures in different
countries so this will take some times
in different parliaments
global news canada
thank you very much secretary general
david a from global news
um you were very gracious uh greeting
the canadian prime minister today
secretary general before you have been
very gracious greeting canadian prime
ministers but our spending is just awful
uh it decreased if you measure by gdp it
decreased in absolute terms we're
nowhere near the two percent it's not
your place but i wonder how might you
convince a canadian public a canadian
politician to spend more on defense and
secondarily
what then might a medium or smaller
military power do
contribute with some of this new focus
new spheres of influence in china in
asia as well as the urgent crisis here
in europe thank you of course i expect
all allies to meet the guidelines we
have set and we agreed them back in 2014
for a decade up to 2024
uh and since then the world has just
become more dangerous
and and i have been a politician myself
for many years and i understand that
it's always easier to invest in health
in education and infrastructure instead
of allocating money for defense that's
very easy to understand
and that that was the reason why nato
allies reduced defense spending after
the end of the cold war
but if we reduce defense spending when
tensions are going down we have to be
able to increase defense spending when
tensions are going up and when and when
we live in a more dangerous world and
therefore welcome the fact that all nato
allies have increased defence spending
and added a lot um
not all allies
have plans in place to be at two percent
by 2024 but the vast majority have such
plans
and more and more allies are actually
meeting the two percent target or very
close
so of course this is a message to all
allies including canada
at the same time also welcome the fact
that canada and other allies are
providing a lot of
capabilities um contributions to nato
missions and operations and canada lead
the the battle group in latvia i've been
there together with with with president
uh with prime minister tudor uh and also
with the defense under and the foreign
minister and and also welcome the fact
that canada is not stepping up
its presence in latvia and of course
this also counts a lot uh when it comes
to contributions to our collective
defense
thank you that's i'm afraid all that we
have time for secretary journalist to
meet our indo-pacific partners secretary
general thank you so much
that was jen stoltenberg a nato
secretary general talking uh about the
new nato
commitment
the affirmation of the strength of nato
uh he announced that they have just
agreed what they are calling their new
strategic concept the blueprint for our
alliance in a more competitive world
earlier in the week we told you that
nato was going to increase its ready to
act forces from some 40 000 to 300 000
um the nato summit this week expanding
more on that you heard uh more from jen
stoltenberg on that plan let's go to
madrid our international affairs editor
dominic waghorn uh was listening to that
speech which opens uh the summit today
effectively uh what was what did you
make of the detail uh contained in yen
stottenburg speech
well the secretary general was unveiling
the strategic concept for 2022 now that
is a blueprint really for nato in the
years ahead it is a an assessment of its
values and principles and an assessment
of the security environment that it
believes uh is facing uh its members its
allied members
and so based on that it's a way of
working out what they do about that
security environment how they act and
operate in the years ahead now the last
strategic concept was in back in 2010
when we were in a very different world
and to give you an idea of what it said
back then about russia he said nato
russia cooperation is of strategic
importance as it contributes to creating
a common space of peace stability and
security so back then russia was a
strategic partner or certainly the
aspiration it would be a partner for
nato this is what the strategic concept
says about russia now the russian
federation has violated the norms and
principles that contributed to a stable
and predictable european security order
we cannot discount the possibility of an
attack against allies sovereignty and
territorial integrity so it's gone from
a potential partner to a threat not just
to nato's neighbours but to nato itself
to
europe itself on the continent of europe
and this follows uh what stottenberg
said allies have decided this morning
that they need to transform and
strengthen the alliance in the wake of
russia's invasion of ukraine and it
requires a fundamental shift in our
defense and deterrence position and part
of that away from this strategic concept
as you're saying is this
aspiration to expand the rapid response
force that nato has waiting for its
supreme ally commander to call upon in
the event of an emergency from 40 000
troops to 300 000 troops and in addition
to that there's there are plans now to
massively bolster the number of nato
soldiers and troops that are going to be
permanently stationed in eastern europe
on russia's border because of the threat
of russians russia's attack so it's a
fundamental shift in the way the
alliance is operating and to give you an
idea also about how this strategic
concept is looking at threats away from
russia in 2010 it didn't mention china
this year it's saying that the people's
republic of china stated ambitions and
coercive policies challenge our interest
security and value so a very different
approach to china to russia and also to
climate change that's also mentioned in
the strategic concept so it's a way of
updating and overhauling nato's attitude
to the security environment it believes
it's threatening its allies
and a way of looking ahead to try and
meet those challenges in the years ahead
dominic thank you dominic wagon quite a
lot of detail uh unveiled by nato today
dominic bringing you some of the
highlights we'll continue to discuss it
throughout the afternoon here on sky
news
well at this summit president biden
promised to step up as western leaders
continue to discuss the war in ukraine
the plans to bolster america's military
presence in europe comes as russia
intensifies its attacks in ukraine
boris johnson has also called on nato
members to dig deep in defense of the